so noguchi memorial institute
it's a biomedical research center in
ghana it's part of the university of
ghana
and one of our key mandates is to
conduct biomedical research to inform
public health policies so
malaria as you know is very important
is a very important public health
concern in sub-saharan africa
and that is my core area of
research so as a team
we approach the pine group
what we normally do is to
look at resistance to malaria parasites
why these malaria parasites become
resistant to the anti-malarial drugs
that
our malaria control programs administer
and we advise these policy makers
on the circulating malaria parasites and
why the drugs are not working and they
need to change
drugs not only do we look at drug
resistance we are also interested in
interventions like vaccines
so if for instance a vaccine is being
introduced
we are interested in looking at the
effect of
these vaccines on the circulating
malaria
population in order to see
why this vaccine is not so efficacious
why is it more efficacious in this
region compared to other regions
and we are also interested in
understanding the mechanisms
underlying either resistance or
the efficacy of a vaccine
and so this is something we've been
doing for a while
now we approached pine group to support
us
to um strengthen our bioinformatics
still with the objective of informing
the public health um policies as we've
been doing
so for drug resistance
we are looking at two drugs
or three drugs the sulfadoxane perimeter
which is a synergistic
drug that is used for
prevention of malaria in pregnant women
and in children living in
seasonal malaria regions
in sub-saharan africa so the idea is to
give it
to these people to prevent malaria or
for the children
so that when the transmission peak is
due
they would have had some um drugs and
it will reduce their um
parasite load so we are interested in
genes that are involved in resistance to
this um drug
with pines we've not just looked at
the mutations in these genes that are
involved in resistance
what we've done is to look at the effect
of these
um circulating mutations or variants
in the ghanaian population and in other
african populations to see
the effect of the variant on the protein
structure
or the active sites of the proteins
to understand why resistance is
ongoing we are also tracking
these mutations in
regions outside ghana other african
countries
to see whether the emerging resistance
patterns that we are observing in ghana
are also being replicated elsewhere
or whether some of the resistant
patterns we are observing in ghana
are just localized
patterns that we are seeing and again
the impact on the proteins themselves
now the second drug that we are
interested in is chloroquine
chloroquine as we know is no longer used
in sub-saharan africa to a larger sense
however we are tracking
the re-expansion
of chloroquine sensitive parasites so
it was topped because the parasites had
developed so much resistance to
this draft that there was no need using
it
but when we left this intervention for a
while
we see that there is the re-expansion of
the
sensitive parasites and this is very
important for us to track
one to see how chloroquine can be reused
either as a single dose for
um prevention of malaria
or in combination with other drugs
now the second reason why we are
interested in chloroquine is that
um some of the currently
being used drugs currently we are using
artemisinin in combination with other
drugs like
amuda queen and
lumifantrine now
the re-imagined
chloroquine sensitive paratha parasites
may also cause um
[Music]
resistance to these partner drugs
so it's important to monitor mutations
in these genes that are involved in
chloroquine resistance
not only to track the re-expansion of
chloroquine-sensitive parasites
but also to see the effect of these
sensitive parasites on the drugs that we
are currently
using and again with pine we are not
stopping
at looking at the existence of these
mutations in
our ghanaian population but we are also
interested in how these mutations are
affecting the active site
of the proteins and
trying to understand exactly the
mechanism of resistance how
resistance actually works because yes
chloroquine
we have some ideas but we still do not
understand exactly how
chloroquine wax and how resistance comes
about
because it is more heterogeneous than
you may think of it so we are trying to
understand
how the variant circulating in the
ghanian population are affecting the
structure of the protein and if we find
that
there are important variants either
acting
in synergy with a known
resistant mutations in order to cause
resistance
then our next step is to see exactly
how this is happening through modeling
or molecular dynamics to understand
exactly the interaction or
the effect of these variants on the
protein
now in terms of
vaccines we are interested in candidates
that are being developed for malaria
vaccine
for the second sporozoid protein of the
malaria parasite
it's the only vaccine
that has been developed to the stage
where it's been
approved and it's currently being
introduced on a pilot
scale in a phase 4 trial in four african
three african countries including ghana
malawi and kenya now
our interest as you may know
is that this
vaccine even though has been approved
was
only about 30 to 50 percent efficacious
in certain groups of children five
months to 17 years old
so we are interested in understanding
why
we are not getting an efficacious
malaria vaccine
yes recently just last month one malaria
vaccine
was tested at the phase two level and we
got about 70
efficacy but what has been
approved which is the rtss vaccine
developed from the circumstance protein
was
only as good as 30 percent so
we are interested in understanding why
the vaccine hasn't been effective
efficacious
we've done this by looking at the
diversity
of the vaccine antigen that is the csp
the second sporozoid
protein across ghana
and we can see that the
epitope or the gene
is so diverse in ghana and
there is within region diversity and
there is no way such a vaccine
will give us even the 30 percent
efficacy that we are expecting we are
not expecting to see the same
in different regions of ghana
we are also interested in looking at
how these circulating variants again
affect the function of the antigen
how it is affecting the t
cell epitopes and
the reason why the vaccine
is not efficacious and
lately with covert 19
we've also developed interest in
understanding why
um we seem to have
less mortality in sub-saharan africa
and even the severity of covet
19 is not as severe as
in the western world comparing
[Music]
the cases to sub-saharan africa and
in ghana particularly
so with time we are developing
a program or what we call the covered
malaria
initiative to understand what is
happening we have
hypothesized that repeated infections
with
malaria parasites might have
sustained our immune system
[Music]
such that people are able to handle
covet even though you may be infected
with a virus
virus you're able to handle it better
than people living in the western world
we are aware of um factors such as
the age grouping for
um death from covet in the western world
we know that
our um um
we tend to have a younger population in
sub-saharan africa
we are aware of environmental
or socio-economic fact test that may
influence
um covet 19
disease but we think
that immune responses to malaria might
have contributed so
we are looking at
differences in gene expression profiles
in people with mild and severe covered
covet 19 in relation to people
who are partially immune as a result of
repeated infections from malaria
parasites
to understand which genes are more
highly expressed in order to understand
why um covet 19 mortality
is less in sub-saharan africa we're also
interested
in looking at the differences in
cytokine responses between
people who are partially immune as a
result of
repeated malaria infections compared to
covered 19
cases and also they are interested
in immune response cells
that are involved in these two diseases
all in a bit to understand um
why covet 19 mortality is much higher
in um the western world compared to
sub-saharan africa we as a group
have tabbed on in the um
genomics studies that prime biotech has
conducted and we are also looking at the
transcriptomics
to undertake these projects and it's
been a very very
good experience and i would encourage a
lot of you to
partake especially in this program
so thank you very much